a guess who was on that bus from uh Eric
Holder and he got a kill nip on
everything I loved he was he was right
there on the same bus and it's crazy
because I'm chained up I'm with a few
homies I'm gonna help me from 60s too
but he's in a cage though he was pc'd up
but he was in the in the last cage and I
and I'm sitting right here so like his
cage is right here I see him really just
look back I'm like what the [__] and I
tell the homie I'm like hey I think
that's old boy bam I go bang on his on
his window boom boom boom he looks back
everybody on the bus like what the [__]
I swear to God and then he's like you
Eric you Eric Holder he's like yeah this
[__] went crazy everything he got pissed
on and Samosa spit on they were pissing
and spitting on him in the bus hell yeah
squirting piss on his ass somebody like
him like can't beat like he has to not
be in general population because he does
as soon as we got to Delano they stopped
the bus over on the freeway I mean y'all
better chill out so as soon as we got to
Delano he covered and pissed they take
him out first they put him away like you
know he could show PC that's even on a
PC yard though he's [__] people love
me I'm saying like you don't even got to
be like Affiliated you just like yo you
[__] what you did was [__] bro yeah
even the homies Mexicans we tripping